like dogecoin admittedly it went up a
minute ago
people like oh what's up guys sup bro
gotta buy it
what i want to do is find out what you'd
like to hear a wrap about okay so
everyone here think of a word a topic or
phrase that you'd like to rap about
feel free to be creative
[Music]
we'll take five suggestions um and we'll
divide them up so
so what what did you just shout at the
top of your lungs dogecoin dogecoin did
you get in at the bottom
i guess at the top at the top that's the
bad thing to do
right i got i bought when it hit 40
cents i now have no money left
where where is dogecoin now how's it
doing no idea no idea so you own it
it peaked yeah it did it did thank you
very much that in a different context
that would be an
awful heckle just this set peaked now
he's just talking about
cryptocurrency so dogecoin is a good
suggestion let's take that
um let's uh get a suggestion from you
guys over here
oh so the previous comments about so
ricky was wearing velcro sneakers is
that
case what sneakers were they so
okay velcro van sneakers did you say
that there was something else
they were white great we're doing a real
kind of like murder mystery solving
together
this is great the previous comics so
we'll just say white velcro van sneakers
thank you
were you pointing at a friend over here
yeah let's get in the mix big group of
ladies over there cool please don't
uh hex me so dogecoin the salem witch
trials
the white
[Music]
just to clarify that's the toy that goes
down the stairs right
cool good i don't know i i've had times
when people suggest things and i
do a rap and people go that's not what
we mean by that in our country
people over here what do you want a
rapper
joe biden yeah cool and i love you yes
sir as well
are you related to him it was very
polite
it was very right yesterday
okay cool jump
i can't tell whether you're pro or
auntie but that's fine we'll find out in
the rat um
okay so to remind you we have dogecoin
the salem witch trials
white velcro vans sneakers um joe biden
and uh slinky this then lovely people
i'm gonna i'm gonna plug my own phone in
because i'm not cool enough to have a dj
yeah
this is a freestyle rack that has a wrap
made up on the spot based
entirely on suggestions not written not
prepared not rehearsed and i don't want
you to worry
it's not going to be anywhere near as
atrociously embarrassingly toe-curlingly
bad
as you're expecting a privately educated
middle class white british boy to be
you don't seem very convinced to remind
you joe biden
white velcro band sneakers dogecoin
slinky in the salem witch trials
all freestyle all improvised in mainer
let's do this
with a mask even if he's out even though
he changed it recently he went farther
than anyone before because he chose
kamala like
hi i'm from the north east pacific leo
specifically i say the least about biden
a democrat
had a son in the war who died in iraq
while after he came back the other one
still alive but the cocaine going on
hunt abided
everybody he was on his knees apparently
he smoked parmesan
cheese believing it was crack that's a
true fact i read it on fox so i might
take back
that it doesn't even matter yeah i want
a while away and always another look for
another child trial away
like a witch when i'm there with the
stage if you lay the assailant don't
make the mistake
of saying anything what you thought or
casting any spell
or having a war on your nose otherwise
the witch finder's gonna say
oh goody johnson i find you over here
get me take you to the pond
do you float do you sink how long do you
stay under the water
going down usually they'd say she was
innocent but she drowned that's a very
true fact don't own a black cat
otherwise they'll burn you with your
little black hat and your broomstick
do this mistake and let me move on here
go in there from salem
admittedly it went up a minute ago
people like oh
sup guys sun bro gotta buy it no don't
worry we trust we got a tweet sent out
by elon musk he's a great guy
he has got it all together very clever
on his managing spacexl
it was like dogecoin to the moon you got
in at the top
well not too soon but that's okay you
don't know the value based on a little
meme everybody i should tell you
please do your research it's not good if
you start buying all this stuff
on robin hood like game stop stop but
it's stonking everybody's sitting down
there
and now walking getting on the stage
sound coming out the speakers wish i had
a cool pair of velcro sneakers
but i don't but that's okay if they were
white
i take a day to learn how to tie my
laces don't need loop and i
i just put a little hook then i get the
velcro
that's the plant who makes it off the
wall that's vans
that's the name there of the branch
that's a freestyle app thank you
[Applause]